[Music]
I'll make you proud
I know the world will never get over
losing Cameron boys he gave us the best
childhood and never failed to make us
laugh so to further honor this star who
left us too soon here are 10 of the best
Luke moments from Disney Channel's
Jessie watch until the end for our
absolute favorite moment crushing on
Jessie one of Luke's most adorable
qualities was that he was a hopeless
romantic in season 1 of Jessie he pulled
out all the stops in trying to persuade
Jessie to be his girlfriend
he tried flirty conversations ours will
be a forbidden love and dressing up
fancy to score a highly anticipated date
with her even tricked her into standing
under the mistletoe so he could get a
kiss Jessie told him repeatedly that she
was too old for him but he didn't seem
to mind it was too cute to watch dance
moments fans of Cameron Boyce know that
he was an incredible dancer ever since
he was a little kid he had some wicked
cool moves a forced Disney Channel gave
him an opportunity to show off those
moves in Jessie he as a partner he has a
background in breakdancing which made it
easy to pull off the choreography in the
show whether Luke was strutting out of
his bedroom to celebrate the weekend
shining on stage with his dance crew or
mimicking the iconic scene from risky
business he always made fans cheer when
he danced James Bond impersonation one
of the funniest scenes from Jessie takes
place in Luke's imagination he's driving
a fancy car with Jessie in the passenger
seat they're dressed to the nines and
speaking with British accents he saved
me just in time Luke is doing his best
James Bond impression Ross Luke Ross
true to form he tries to get Jessie who
calls herself dimples galore to give him
a high-speed kiss she politely declines
by ejecting him from the car still you
can't blame a kid for trying
epic fail Luke never lost his flair for
romance so it was totally in character
when he set up an elaborate display to
ask his new crush Nora to the dance blow
her mind so we set up a confetti cannon
a marching band
to sign that red let's go dance the
night away Nora unfortunately Jessi set
it off too soon and accidentally ripped
the sign changing it to go away Nora and
of course that's when she walked in it
was an epic fail it's the practical joke
poor sweet Luke the eyebrow incident it
would be very difficult for Luke to look
anything less than adorable but this
scene makes him look absolutely
hilarious Ravi is trying to pull a
plaster mask off of Luke's face but he's
having trouble when he finally succeeds
it becomes clear that Luke left a part
of himself in that mask we'll give you
two hints we're talking about his
eyebrows that scream he belts out always
makes everyone laugh seriously how did
he manage to stay so cute even without
eyebrows is koala we all have something
that we cleaned to for comfort Luke's
favorite thing to snuggle at night was
Kenny koala we love remembering the
scene in which Jesse tried to get Luke
to give up his cuddle bear you gotta
leave the bear let's just say it didn't
go well at all after dreaming about his
bear all night he decided he couldn't go
without his favorite stuffed animal
he came rushing back for Kenny and it
was the sweetest thing ever
bunny stunts one major reason the Disney
Channel cast Cameron Boyce in the role
of Luke was his comedic timing and
ability to pull off hilarious stunts
because he was such a good dancer timing
was totally his thing he made us laugh
with his goofy Falls like when he ran
into Bertram he could act silly like
nobody else and we all loved him for it
Cameron sure knew how to make people
laugh it was one of his many talents
nice hair Luke again it's pretty hard to
make Cameron voice go from heartthrob to
goofball but he pulled it off repeatedly
in the show
in this scene Luke is rocking a reverse
mohawk courtesy of Bertram terrible
shaving skills shaved me Cameron was
clueless as he walked up and noticed
people laughing at him we don't know how
he managed to pull off that crazy scream
but it gets us every time are we the
only ones who still think he's handsome
even with a big bald spot in the middle
of his head lizard call Cameron Boyce
was a caught drupal threat he could act
sing dance and do lizard cause what's a
lizard call you might ask it goes a
little something like this
in this scene his character Luke is
searching for Robbie's Blizzard he rolls
his tongue and lets out a high-pitched
sound from his mouth with intermittent
hissing noises
[Applause]
we love how he totally embodies a
dinosaur from Jurassic Park when he does
the lizard call that's not something
every actor can do dog act one of our
favorite Luke moments of all time was
when he discovered that Jessie had been
treating him like a dog so that he would
obey her you do a homework problem you
will get a brownie she was in for a rude
awakening when she came downstairs and
so I'm actually acting like a dog he
ripped that pillow to shreds and he
makes the cutest puppy dog ever while we
can't believe Cameron Boyce is gone we
can always look back at these funny
heartwarming moments from the show and
remember him he was a bright light in
this world who made people happy with
his mini talents will never forget you
Cameron we know that wherever you are
you're making
the Angels laugh rust in peace Cameron
boys what are your favourite loose
moments from Disney Channel's Jessie we
hope you'll join us in paying tribute to
Cameron by writing your favourite
memories of him in the comments and
don't forget to subscribe to the things
Channel and give this video a big thumbs
up thank you for watching
[Music]